ça va pas ouais ça va bien on tente de
faire ce tournage avec toi ben ça fait
plaisir moi si ça fait zizir ce plaisir
exactement
voilà je te laisse te présenter à je
suis le papa de cyrus c'est très simple
je suis un entrepreneur multirécidiviste
dans internet logiciel est tout ça est
la dernière entreprise c'était aux états
unis que je les lancers et a toujours
récusé ou avant j'étais hours cunti et
avant c'était à paris et donc vu que tu
as vécu longtemps en france et que
maintenant ça fait longtemps qu aux
etats unis c'est peut-être la bonne
personne pour ce t'imagines si ça me
fait un bon candidat pts imagine si ya
pas encore de génériques mais ça arrive
bon en fait on a entendu la vidéo de
tout à l'heure maintenant il ya ya et il
a aussi qui disent agir est présenté
pour moi pas ou une courte seconde
guerre mondiale
car les us auraient directement été
attaqués donc une contre attaque plus
forte plus rapide la france n'aurait
jamais été occupée et c'est là notre
côté par son éloignement des autres
états on peut penser que l'état français
ressemblerait à une base militaire j'ai
entre les us seraient beaucoup plus
présents sur les dossiers chauds crimée
problème en afrique du nord même
moyennement travail bien sûr mais en
fait ce qu'il est en train de dire
je sais pas de qui avait testé en
batiste d'abord merci baptiste c'est que
déjà sens à des états unis ont une
position dominante mais même super
dominante dans le monde
wahou qu'est ce que ça a donné 6 25% de
la géographie de l'europe et 20% à 25%
de son pib faisait partie des états unis
c'est énorme façon dont la france serait
très différente aussi par rapport à
l'architecturé le cinéma et plein
d'autres choses de ce style la question
est de oliviera dit merci aux libyens
merci olivier dassault aviation bon je
pense que ça revient sur le sujet qui
est revenu plusieurs fois c'est des
particularités culturelles françaises ou
est-ce que les particularités d'un état
américain sont conservés ou est ce que
au contraire elles sont absorbées par
les états ou les exemples genre a while
par exemple ça montre que ça a plutôt
tendance à on conserve chaque état
conserve sa quantité d'ailleurs c'est
marrant les gens ne savent pas forcément
mais même les plaques d'immatriculation
205 différentes à une fonction de chaque
état avec une scène on va pas avec les
terres en question genre l'arizona et un
cactus tout la californie je crois que
c'est un peu d'herbe genre de la
mercerie et donc de leur choix oui ou
non vous savez ce n'est pas d'acheter
montagne alors qu'un lien d'accès
bancaire t'imagines si la france était
un état des usa la france sort et l'état
plus peuplé des usa et ce serait le
swing states qui ferait toutes les
élections présidentielles du fait de sa
population et ses différences
culturelles avec le continent donc swing
states et un état dont les résultats
sont rangeant la population et aussi
bien démocrates que républicains
par contre le sujet est intéressant si
la france était un état des etats-unis
vu sa population je pense qu'elle aurait
un très grand nombre de grands électeurs
qui est proportionnelle à son économie
et sa population donc il n'ya pas de
règles exactes mais en gros ça donc ça
oh elle aurait le plus grand nombre de
grands électeurs de gauche donc deux
démocrates
d'une manière générale l'ensemble des
élections serait beaucoup plus à gauche
que ce qu'on connaît le fromage français
disparaîtrait car c'est interdit la base
c'est pareil je peux pas vivre sans moi
je pensais c'est quoi les
chocolats milka 74 fera tout à fait
éclater m'engage
heureusement le fromage français n'est
pas interdit à l'or fin 2005 il sort sa
dune à la préparation de la guerre
d'irak
jacques chirac sait pas quand il s'est
opposé et donc il n'a pas suffi
bush dans sa coalition internationale et
donc à ce moment-là je sois bouche à
bouche à bouche
il me semble sûr c'est ma mémoire est
bonne c'était à ce moment là qu'il ya eu
une
[Musique]
une mesure de certains états du middle
west américain qui dit on arrête importe
le fromage penser il par contre le foie
gras où il est il a été interdite
plusieurs fois en californie
pour des questions de protection des
animaux
si la france faisait partie des états
unis on aurait pas de sécurité sociale
et faire des études coûterait une blinde
ça dépend aussi des états donc si la
france faisait partie des états unis et
conserverait à mon avis ces aspects là
par exemple la californie à médical qui
est spécifique avec california qui
couvre les l'assurance maladie mehdi
câble californien médicale c'est une
spécificité californienne qui couvrent
l'assurance maladie et genre en dessous
d'un certain niveau de rémunération
ainsi que les gens de plus de 65 ans
indépendamment de leur niveau de vie
donc on peut parfaitement imaginer la
même chose avec un état français qui
aurait ses propres règles mais qui
aurait aussi ses propres impôts niveau
d'imposition au niveau d'imposition de
la californie n'est pas de même qu'au
texas californie taxes aux plus d'abri
aux usa veine tva alors que green des
états qui ont pâti la veille ça
s'appelle safe taxe qui est de 2 9% 8,8
et quelques pourcents au pardon set et
demi qu'on semble
en californie et s'est plus ou moins
importantes dans d'autres états pareil
pour l'éducation jusqu'au niveau bac + 2
contrairement à ce qu'on peut imaginer
en france aux états unis on peut avoir
d'éducation sans frais de scolarité dans
les community college qui ont un niveau
très élevé partout dans les hes ou juste
en californie cet acte je pense que
c'est partout dans les eaux nationales
or enrôler réponse est non la france
pourrait garder ses spécificités
sociales quoi bas au moins on aura des
besoins
apparemment ne rate des boissons 5
litres qu'on aura des besoins de 5
litres aussi si la france est un état
des états unis par exemple depuis la fin
de la seconde guerre mondiale je pense
que le pays serait une sorte de mélange
entre la corse à hawaï et le québec
on serait parfaitement bilingue on
serait très autonome mais on aurait
quand même nos courant indépendantiste
on aurait sûrement encore plus la
réputation de snob mais une bonne partie
des américains à prendre est le français
pour se la péter
les anglais nous aurait détesté pour
être donnés américain et peut-être qu'il
aurait aussi 10 aurait aussi voulu
devenir américain cette crise
mathieu verdin bisous mathieu c'est
super c'est bien dit je suis j'y adhère
à 100 % est-ce que vous avez passé un
bon ouais merci de plaisir pour la
prochaine fois
voici la question à laquelle il faut
répondre tu imagines si le cannibalisme
était très courant avec les eaux de la
chaîne dirty biologie si vous découvrez
ce format et vous connaissez pas le
concept vous invite à regarder dans la
description je vous donne plus de
détails
et parmi toutes les réponses qui sont
dans le prochain épisode il ya une
personne qui gagnera un jeu tu imagines
si et c'est pas rien parce que je
rappelle que c'est le meilleur jeu du
monde
bisous l'eau qui s'écoule ok mais sympa
bisous bisous dire avec la bis à yala
[Rires]